Spirituális alapok, bevezetés a
királyságba.
Keressétek először Isten országát és az
ő igazságát, és mindezek ráadásként
megadatnak majd nektek. Máté evangéliuma
hatodik fejezet 33. vers. Jézus soha nem
mondta semmire azt, hogy keressétek
először csak az Isten országával,
királyságával kapcsolatban. Jézus
számára az Isten királysága volt az
első. többet beszélt róla, mint bármi
másról, beleértve az egyházat is. A négy
evangéliumban a királyság szó görögül
Basileja 109zer fordul elő, míg az
egyház szó görögül eklészia csak
háromszor.
Ha Jézus ennyit beszélt róla, nem
furcsa, hogy mi alig tesszük ezt. De mit
jelent tulajdonképpen az Isten
királysága? Egy királyság egyszerűen az
a terület, ahol egy adott király
uralkodik. Isten királysága az a hely,
ahol ő uralkodik. ahol az ő akarata
teljesül. Az a hely, ahol méltán látják
trónon ülőként őt, aki védelmet és
gondoskodást nyújt, és aki királyként
megérdemli osztatlan hűségünket.
Ez az a hely, ahol Isten ügyei válnak a
legfőbb ügyekké. A királyság
Istenrendjének megjelenése az emberi
ügyekben. Dr. Jack Taylor így határozza
meg Isten királyságát. Isten örök uralma
minden és mindenki felett, mindenhol,
minden időben és az örökkévalóságban.
Mindez az idő felett áll, mégis magában
foglalja az időt. Meghaladja az időt, és
időtálló. Milliárd korszakokkal ezelőtt
Isten királysága már létezett, és sok
milliárd év múlva is létezni fog. Mivel
örökkévaló, kiérdemli, hogy mindenségnek
nevezzék, mert minden más vagy benne
foglaltatik, vagy végül megszűnik
létezni. Jézusnak szinte minden
példázata a királyságról szól.
Történetei királyságról szóló történetek
voltak, imái pedig királyságról szóló
imák. Jézus állandóan erről beszélt. Az
első szavak, amelyeket Jézus Máté és
Márk evangéliumaiban mondott, a
királyságról szóltak. Keresztrefeszítése
és feltámadása után Jézus 40 napon
keresztül jelent meg tanítványainak.
Sokan azt várták, hogy elkezdi
előkészíteni a távozását, és az egyház
megszervezésére vonatkozó útmutatást ad.
De ő folytatta ugyanazt a témát. Egy 40
napos konferenciát tartott a
királyságról.
Szenvedése után sok bizonyítékkal meg is
mutatta nekik, hogy ő él, amikor 40
napon át megjelent előttük, és beszélt
az Isten országa dolgairól. Apostolok
cselekedetei első fejezet harmadik vers.
Az apostolok cselekedetei Jézusnak a
királyságról szóló prédikációjával
kezdődik, és Pál apostol hasonló
témájával végződik. Ő pedig itt maradt
két teljes esztendeig saját bérelt
szállásán, és fogadta mindazokat, akik
felkeresték. Hirdette az Isten országát,
és tanított az Úr Jézus Krisztusról
teljes bátorsággal minden akadályoztatás
nélkül. Apostolok cselekedetei 28.
fejezet 30-31-es vers. A könyvet, amely
az apostolok cselekedetei címet viseli,
keretbe foglalja a királyság, mint
fókuszpont. Az apostolok nem egyszerűen
az egyház vagy a megváltás hírét
terjesztették, hanem a királyságot
hirdették. Sok hívő úgy tekint Isten
királyságára, mint amit csak Krisztus
visszatérése után tapasztalhat meg. Ez a
nézet azonban megfosztja a hívőket a
jelenben mind az erőtől, mind a céltól.
Az írások azt tanítják, hogy Isten
királysága már eljött, most jön el és
még el fog jönni. Az egyik
legcsodálatosabb igazság Isten
szeretettörténetében az, hogy aktív
szerepre hív minket az ő világrendjének
helyreállításában és királyságának
valósággá tételében a földön, úgy ahogy
az a mennyben van. A királyságban élve
hatalmunk és megbízatásunk van arra,
hogy kiterjesszük azt a területet, ahol
Isten uralkodik, és ahol az ő akarata
teljesül. Isten nem azt akarja, hogy
várjunk a mennybe jutásra, hanem hogy
kövessük Jézust, mint a mennyország
állampolgárai, és hozzuk a mennyet a
földre az élet minden területén, az
üzletben, a politikában, az oktatásban
és a saját befolyási körünkben. Ez az
átalakulás először bennünk történik,
majd körülöttünk, lángra robbantva a
világot megbocsátással, gyógyulásokkal,
csodákkal, igazságossággal és békével.
Isten célja az Édenkert óta változatlan.
Arra lettünk teremtve, hogy uralkodjunk
az ő egész teremtésén. De az, hogy mi
ezzel a lehetőséggel hogyan sáfárkodunk,
attól függ, hogy ő uralkodik-e
felettünk. A királyságban élni azt
jelenti, hogy a szemléletünk
megváltozik. Ne az én akaratom legyen
meg, hanem a tiéd. Lukács evangéliuma
22. fejezet 42. vers. És a vágyunk
ugyanaz lesz, mint Jézusé. Jöjjön el a
te országod. Legyen meg a te akaratod,
amint a mennyben, úgy a földön is. Máté
evangéliuma hatodik fejezet 10. vers. A
királyságban a hódolat megváltott
formáját tapasztaljuk meg. Ahelyett,
hogy egyszerűen csak egy uralkodó
parancsának kényszerű betartása lenne, a
hódolat aktiválja a Szentlélek erejének
áramlását bennünk és körülöttünk. Sajnos
az egyház elhagyta a királyság központi
üzenetét, és felváltotta a megváltás
üzenetének hirdetésével.
Az első század végére Jézus üzenete a
királyságról és annak hatalmáról szinte
teljesen elveszett. A sátán tudta, hogy
ha el tudja lopni ezt az üzenetet és
rejtve tudja tartani, akkor elveszünk.
Ennek következményeként sok hívő vak a
királyság valóságára. Ez a vakság sokba
kerül, mert Isten földi királyságának
megvan a hatalma és az ereje, hogy
forradalmasítsa kultúránkat. A megváltás
örömhíre csupán egy része annak a
királyságüzenetnek, amelyet Jézus
hirdetett. A teljes evangélium magába
foglalja az engesztelés és a királyság
örömhírét is. A megváltás a kapu a
királyságba, de Isten ennél sokkal
többet készített számunkra, amikor újra
felfedezzük, mit jelent már a jelenben
is a királyság szerint élni. De hogyan
kapcsolódik a királyság Krisztus
egyházához? A királyság üzenete nem
egyfajta helyettesítő teológia. Az
egyház Isten tervének fontos része. De a
királyság nem fér bele az egyházba. Az
egyház illeszkedik a királyságba.
Az egyház csupán egy olyan terület, ahol
Isten rendjét kell megalapozni, de ha
itt megállunk, akkor elmulasztjuk a
lényeget. Feladatunk, hogy kiterjesszük
az ő királyságát minden befolyási
területünkre. Amikor alárendeljük
magunkat az ő uralmának, minden hely,
ahová a lábunk lép, a királyság
területévé válik. A királyság
felfedezése nem csupán információ, hanem
egy egész életen áttartó kaland az
isteni kinyilatkoztatásban és
átalakulásban.
Az igazság az, hogy soha nem tudjuk
teljesen megérteni vagy szavakba önteni
a királyságot.
Ezért használt Jézus olyan gyakran
hasonlatot. Isten országa, királysága,
hasonló nem írható le közvetlenül, mert
örökkévaló és kozmikus méretű. Ez túl
nagy ahhoz, hogy emberi mi voltunkban
megértsük, és az örökkévalóságot is
azzal fogjuk tölteni, hogy felfedezzük.
Ha meg tudod határozni vagy magyarázni,
akkor az nem a királyság. Készi Bru.
Mondhatja azt valaki, ha látnám, akkor
keresném, de nem a látással van a
problémánk, hanem a nézéssel. Amit keres
a tekintetünk, azt meglátjuk. Amit
meglátunk, azt óhatatlanul keresni
fogjuk. Vajon reggel arra számítva
ébredünk, hogy a királyság jeleit fogjuk
aznap látni, vagy csak olyan dolgokat
észlelünk, amiket mások véletlennek
neveznek? Isten szándékosan és
folyamatosan ad nekünk bepillantási
lehetőségeket a királyságba. Ezek
körülöttünk történnek, de gyakran nem
vesszük észre, mert nem keressük. De ha
keressük, hamarosan várni fogjuk ezeket
a jeleket, aztán hinni fogunk bennük, és
tudatában leszünk jelenlétüknek az
életünkben. A királyság az egyetlen
megingadhatatlan örök valóság. Zsidókhoz
írt levél 12. fejezet 28. vers. Semmi,
amit láthatunk vagy megérinthetünk, nem
örök. Lehet értékes, de nem örökkévaló.
Nem a láthatóság és kézzel foghatóság
határozza meg a valóságot. A valóság
legjobb mércéje nem a láthatóság, hanem
a maradandóság.
Dr. Jet Taylor, aki régóta keresi a
királyságot és sokak által tisztelt
lelkipásztor, azt mondta, hogy
reggelente azzal az érzéssel ébred,
mintha Isten egészéljel próbált volna
beszélni vele. Van egy látomása, hogy
amint kinyitja a szemét, Isten azt
mondja, azt hittem, sosem ébredsz fel.
Jack így válaszol: Uram, hajnali három
óra van. Erre Isten azt mondja: "Már úgy
vártam, új élményeim vannak számodra a
királyságról. Alig várom, hogy
megmutassam neked. Annyi új része van az
én királyságomnak, amiket szeretnék
feltárni előtted, hogy alig bírtam
magammal." Jack azt mondta, hogy ilyen
az ő istene, és ezért kell nekünk is
keresnünk az ő királyságát. Mindannyian
keresünk valamit. Valójában az életünk
azt tükrözi vissza, amit keresünk. Ha
olyasmit választottunk, ami véges, az
látszani fog az életünkön. Jézus azt
mondta, keressétek először Isten
országát. Ez egy parancs, és az a
nyelvtani forma, amit használ,
folyamatos keresést jelent.
Parancsolatot kaptunk, hogy mindig
keressük Isten országát. A legbiztosabb,
amit tehetsz, hogy azt mondod, Istenem,
feladom. Bocsáss meg, hogy eddig a saját
akaratomat követtem a tiéd helyett.
Része akarok lenni annak, amit te
cselekszel. Segíts, hogy először a te
országodat keressem. Egy nő egyszer egy
étteremben szerette volna megkapni egy
étel receptjét, de a szakács azt mondta:
"Odaadnám, de akkor meg kellene ölnöm."
Ez hasonló ahhoz, amit Isten mond a
királyságáról. Akarod a királyságot?
Rendben, de meg kell halnod önmagad
számára. Nem kellemes meghalni, de még
nyomorúságosabb meghalás nélkül élni.
Gyakran úgy tűnik, mintha a királyságban
fejreállnának a dolgok, mert annyira
ellenkulturálisak és természetfelettiek.
Elveszíted, hogy megnyerd.
Meghalsz, hogy élj, szenvedsz, hogy
uralkodj, gyengülsz, hogy megerősödj.
A királyság misztérium, de Isten arra
vágyik, hogy ezt a misztériumot feltárja
nekünk, és rajtunk keresztül másoknak
is. Ha először a királyságot keresed,
mindezek megadatnak neked.
Ezerféleképpen megszerezheted, amit
akarsz, de csak úgy kaphatod meg az
igazán szükséges dolgokat, ha a végső
mindenséget keresed, vagyis a királyt és
az ő királyságát.
Élhetsz jól, de igazán beteljesült
életet csak úgy élhetsz, ha igazodsz a
hatalmas Istenhez. aki a világegyetemet
tartja. Ezt könnyen túlbonyolíthatjuk.
Pedig a királyság annyira egyszerű, hogy
mindössze két szóval meg lehet
határozni.
Isten uralkodik.
Amikor stresszesek vagyunk, szorongunk
vagy félünk, emlékeznünk kell erre az
igazságra, és ragaszkodnunk kell hozzá.
Sőt, Isten meghív bennünket, hogy
vegyünk részt az ő királyságának
földrehozatalában.